i want to talk to you guys about guns
because i had this tweet this friday so
i want to talk about my tweet oh i
tweeted the government should provide
all 16 year olds with a free ar-15 after
they pass firearm ed in high school oh
yeah if you haven't then once you turn
18 you should be entitled to one free
ar-15 from the government after passing
a general knowledge test department of
gun services demand universal gun
ownership now call your member of
congress and demand they pass this
legislation a lot of people said that i
was trolling i'm not my point was that i
saw all these memes from the left where
they said we should treat guns like we
treat cars
and i was like you think that goes only
one way they post these memes where
they're like gotta get a license gotta
get insurance gotta register the gun all
of that stuff and i was like okay i can
use that same argument go the other
direction
we allow 16 year olds to drive cars
okay so 16 year olds should get guns we
also have uh gun rights in the
constitution so you want to argue for
universal health care i'll argue for my
universal
demand as well government should pay for
my guns but let me tell you where the
juicy part of the tweet is at
karl marx said
under no pretext should workers
surrender their arms and ammunition the
true leftist position on guns should be
an armed workforce and the government
providing guns to the people it's just
simple logic karl marx right he said
never surrender your arms and ammunition
well if you're a socialist you don't
think capital is going to fund the
creation of these guns do you it's going
to be the government and they're going
to provide it tim did aoc retweet this i
is that what i'm saying did she like and
retweet
no i'm saying no she will no no you know
that's strange why not i think the only
problem i have with this tweet is that i
don't think getting your gun from the
government is the best thing because if
they really want to conquer you they'll
make the gun have a defect and then give
it to you and they know how to exploit
the defect i'm not saying the only place
to get the gun oh okay i'm saying you
get a free one so it's a net positive
and you've got to get you you'll
probably want to get it checked out but
universal gun ownership they want to
argue for universal health care i'm like
okay cool well they say health care is a
human right i say gun ownership is a
human right right okay well then the
government can pay for it and give
everybody guns
there we go any objections no all right
there it is your right to own does not
dictate a right to receive well of
course i agree okay yeah sorry for the
logic i think my only question is uh
at the 30 000 foot level what are we
considering the age of adulthood so if
it's 16 and i know you can drive at 16
some places in rural you can get your a
farmer's license to drive heavy
equipment at 14. you can't go on the
road but you can drive a 500 000 combine
right it's pretty awesome
but but
there's another movement though to move
the gun ownership age to 21. and i have
a problem with uh
voting at a certain age
but voting on something that you cannot
fully own and free society at another
age because are you
i don't want to be able to vote at 18
but i can't own something until i'm 21.
there's the movement as you were saying
to vote at 16. so 16 year olds are gonna
make law or vote for laws but i can't
fully participate in that law for five
more years so if we're going to have a
real equitable society to use their
words then if you have the right to vote
on something you must have the ability
to have full participation in that
agreement if we're going to make the
voting age 16 then the gun age is 16 but
then the draft is 16 but i don't want my
16 year old sending my 21 year olds to
war telling the 18 year olds they can't
have a cigarette or beer or a gun so
something is wrong if we're going to say
the age of adulthood now is 21 and we
are a very immature society then it's 21
across the board i have a i have a
darker interpretation of their desire
for a 16 year old voting age well
they're stupid well no offense to them
listening it's not just stupidity it's
if you're an adult at 16 that means you
can do more than vote yeah that's what
i'm thinking it's a slippery slope yeah
because at what point can you have sex
with a 35 year old you know 16 years
what are they trying to do this is why
when they try and lo lower the age of
adulthood in a variety of ways i'm kind
of like what's what are you really doing
when you when you look at what's going
on in these schools
you know the grooming and i see these
memes from these liberals on facebook
where they desperately try to conflate
the grooming argument with banning books
and it's just like i see this meme and
it's you know they want to ban books and
there's like an old man with a maghet
yelling and i was like i think they were
concerned about the graphic depictions
of adult activities and those books that
were available to children if you're
defending that yeah and you're doing out
of ignorance
or it's willful
then either way the outcome is the same
when you come out and then say
kids should be you know participating in
governance at 16 it's like you're you're
creating a threshold for which we reduce
the age of adulthood
um i i look i don't know if 18
you know where that number comes about
because it's certainly 200 years ago was
you know you were you're 13 you're
considered a man or whatever i don't
know if i agree with that 18 kind of
feels okay you know gun ownership and
all these things
you can be under 18 and have a gun if
your parents take responsibility for it
in most places like in wisconsin and
stuff like that
i mean you know growing up uh family
farm we hunted you know from when i was
a very young boy but that was part of
our culture we were taught how to use a
firearm respect a firearm and so it's uh
this idea that a 16 year old couldn't or
a 14 year old couldn't i mean use a
firearm and be taught how to use it
thoughtfully is just it's bizarre to me
because i grew up in that culture yeah
yeah so i was shooting from the time i
was like 10 years old yeah my dad took
us we had like a little shooting range
in our back 40
probably not really on on par with what
the law wanted but my dad taught us how
to use it he taught us how to be safe
with it he said i'll give you a dollar
if you ever see the end of this gun
while i'm holding it and of course he'd
never gave us a dollar because we never
saw it and we understood how important
that was but somebody on twitter earlier
today i forget who it was i'm sorry
tweeted how many of these mass shooters
were young boys raised by fathers who
taught them how to hunt it's a very
valid question i don't think any of them
ever have been they don't they have no
dads of course not yeah it's very sad
so that's why when i in the days after
these shootings and we hear congress
stand up and say we need to pass this
law or that law this is the stuff this
is the conversation that we need to have
as a country understanding who these
individuals are their families the
dynamics the health you know mental
health all that because you were so
writing whoever said uh tweeted that
bravo to them because that's spot on
yeah and and i remember thinking um i
actually had this conversation before i
left the healthcare field with one of my
co-workers um and his dad wasn't really
involved in his life and there was a
shooting and i was like this is terrible
but man i think one of the things that
all of these shooters have in common is
that they don't have dads and he's like
huh that's weird i really have to think
about that he's like that's a super hot
take i'm like i think it's true sorry
it's afraid it's a couple things it's a
dad to sit down with you and say son you
need to understand responsibility and
what it means to be to have you know to
have obligations to your community and
it's also the moment when the dad pops
you on the head and said that was dumb
what do you feel stupid yeah i'm so
strong leader dad to be like how are you
feeling
yeah are you okay yeah maybe like a dad
who's got like long hair and it's like a
hippie with a bunch of crystals yeah
maybe you used to smoke weed
oh yeah
look but the point the point here is
that i think that this conversation is
just as valid as hey what about uh
magazine limitations what about the the
type of weapon you know or what about
the age that we should give children of
right i think this conversation is just
as important if not more important but
you hear off so oftentimes from the left
they will say oh here hear the right you
know hear the conservatives go again
talking about family issues and about
you know knock it off come on it's
absolutely it should be part of the
conference
we should have a magazine limit i i
really do think so they shouldn't that
we should limit them to what to uh uh
they cannot be lower than that
at least yeah i knew there was uh
there's a caveat i saw the tail on the
face
if we're gonna look at this outside yes
yes if we're gonna look at society for
the last four generations or so so from
like the baby boomers on
and we're gonna say that gun violence uh
gun school shootings are are the now the
anomaly well we have to look at that in
context right and that's just all they
want to look at is like wow suddenly gun
there are incidents of shootings in
schools uh therefore it's a gun problem
well what else is happening concurrently
right i mean you can't just take one ins
one statistic
and then an isolated and when you look
at everything else that's happening
clearly fatherlessness is a huge problem
sexual perversion is a huge problem you
know what i love about liv libs of tick
tock which is why they got banned from
twitter is i just wish you would find
some liberal teachers who are so
enthusiastic about math and science as
they are about their genitals yeah these
teachers indeed these teachers making
non-stop videos about telling their kids
and i told my girl and it's like dude
like do you ever talk to them about
reading right so so if you look at again
all these millions of statistics of five
generations you can't just look at the
shootings and say wow that's an anomaly
it's a gun problem there's lots of other
things that are spiking and if you say
that while they're not happening there's
no correlation then you're just a liar
or you're politically motivated either
the sexual perversion stuff is is a huge
problem you mentioned the grooming stuff
yeah i mean we have we have hardcore
drag shows
in in children's you know second grade
classroom and and and we're supposed to
pretend this is normal
quite frankly and this is going to sound
hard and i i don't want it to come out
the wrong way i'm surprised there are
not more school shootings because our
kids are so messed up in the head
they're told boys can get pregnant
they're they're they have tampons in
their bathroom they play on girls teams
these kids are so confused with
everything and then their teachers don't
even want to talk about english and math
they want to talk about their dating
lives and and in case anyone out there
starts to text you do know i am married
to a guy yeah right so i am technically
i'm in the community it's a community i
hate it's an alphabet soup that is
degenerative that drives me insane but
but we have to talk about these things
you're you're you're the the way the the
oppression olympics go you're you're out
i'm not a good one yeah you're you're a
you're a victim
but i mean i mean
there's a role for me to play in this
because
you a lot of people you cis people can't
have these conversations the cisgender
you are
scissors am i cis yes oh crap what does
cis mean so not trans not trans so uh
ian and i first
like yeah i knew that was somewhat what
is
all these different words i don't even
know what they mean they don't even have
meaning people will create them like
they don't have any i got no problem
with that to me
if if a group of yeah language evolves
if a group of people are like if someone
isn't trans what are they they call it
sis it's like a math thing i'm like yo i
literally don't care what words you use
as long as you're effectively conveying
ideas to each other are we but the
problem is it's not just the creation of
new words it's the it's the
corruption of existing words like racism
right that's been a huge problem for a
long time as to what racism really means
now
people can come out and say cis and
trans and whatever and i'm like as long
as i understand you we can have a
conversation but we don't understand
each other right ricky gervais is being
cancelled from netflix because of his
transphobic jokes but they they're not
transphobic
jokes about trans people there are jokes
about polish people there are jokes
about catholics but he didn't he didn't
get booted did he well they they were
threatening to you know pull him i'm
sure netflix can't afford to have no
netflix fire their diversity people i'm
pretty sure he's safe he's safe
but i mean it's not a transphobic joke
it's a joke about trans people and if
you're getting made fun of welcome to
the friggin club you know it's like i
remember talking to a mormon when book
of mormon came out and he was saying
that he found a very offensive book of
mormon i was like as a catholic let me
tell you it's about damn time someone
else's religion was made fun of by
mainstream culture so welcome to welcome
to being like everyone else you know
that's what that's what he said ricky
gervais said
he thinks trans people should have
rights and be treated like everyone else
and that's why he's going to make fun of
him boom
he's like that's what true equality is
it is it means if everybody is equal
then everybody is fair game for for
being mine i talked about this a little
bit on pop culture crisis a couple days
ago where we were talking like if
someone like if a soldier loses a limit
in the military in the war or something
you don't like ha ha
you
losing your you like you don't smash
people for what they what they don't
have
but and maybe people feel like that
they're like i'm not normal so you're
making fun of my non-normalcy and that's
really like getting me where i can't
defend myself i get that but at the same
time i don't like like make be making
other people the butt of my jokes i kind
of stopped doing that just in general
although you know one of the things if i
can so i have hung out with a ton of
guys in the military who have lost arms
and legs because of iraq and afghanistan
and i've also hung out with tons of guys
who are in the military and they're gay
or we we have lesbian service members
whatever it may be
the the way that you know that you are
in with that group is with somebody
makes a crack at you yeah that's right i
i was with a guy about 15 guys at a
black rifle coffee company most of those
guys that they hire have have lost limbs
they uh some of those guys when they
walk in you know they'll be like their
legs their arms are really loud and
noisy because they're half [ __ ]
robots right the point is they will make
fun of each other about like hey quiet
down man you're rude we're kind of a
conversation bro and he's like sorry
it's my knee you know but they'll give
each other a hard time and it's this
beautiful moment of like you know that
you
you were in that family a brother by
just getting telling good jokes about it
there's a really great wojack meme where
it's uh a guy is leaving and he's like
he's like see you later [ __ ] and
they'll like screw off you know a-hole
and then it's like f you and then as
soon as he's gone they're like that's a
cool dude right he's great
then it shows the women oh gosh and no
one's like bye honey love you you're so
sweet see you soon and then as soon as
she's gone what a [ __ ]
that's why i don't that's why i have
fewer females friends i think but i
wanted to say too that it does feel
great when somebody makes a joke with
you about something that maybe you can't
even change that you're just like oh
yeah that's actually pretty funny and i
feel now like i'm part of your in-group
it's very valuable it's important so
much of it oh sorry to interrupt there
at the end
capitalize on what you were saying it's
the delivery like if you can deliver it
in an emotionally in a loving way then
it's received in a loving way but when
it's in text no one can comment yeah
amen and they'll take gervaius's jokes
and they'll put them in text and be like
look how horrible yes yeah yeah and
he the the performance has a full arc
how did he get to that point there was a
segway they cut all that out and they
just take the sentence and they're like
context but i just i just love how all
the hit pieces against ricky gervais are
literally what he was complaining about
yeah he was actually talking about the
woke cancel culture and how they're
demanding special privileges because
they don't want to be made fun of but he
was like but everybody is is equal so
we're all gonna be made fun of and then
they write articles saying he's
transphobe and he's violent and he's
dangerous
absolutely absurd yeah but i mean the
alphabet soup which is really run by by
just communists um like like all
minority groups
uh in in in activism right now
you can't have it both ways you can say
this immutable characteristic makes us
so special and so unique and so
different that we have to celebrate it
but we also want to get treated like
everybody else right if you want to get
treated like everybody else that stinks
because when you treat like everybody
else you're standing in line right we
all want you know
like
emerald club status at the airport so
that we can bypass all the lines and we
can have a fancy drink but equality is
not fun so the the alphabet two people
like we want our special and god it's
almost june one and then i have a
oh don't hole don't worry flip your uke
your ukraine flag and put up
your private rainbow
just unfollow all the brands and follow
the saudi arabian ones yeah and you're
good
i love it you said something earlier
daniel that was really interesting where
you said you were almost surprised that
there weren't more shootings i am i
don't want to take a wave too much from
where we're headed with the jokes and
enriquez i love this conversation but i
i've had that same thought like why is
it not but then i'm thinking about
people driving on the road and how so
many people drive past each other all
day on the road over and over these
thousand or you know hundreds of miles
is 140 miles different 70-70 and they
don't hit each other because they don't
want to and most people don't want to
hurt each other it's very very very rare
and it's more of an aberration on these
kids that's causing it i don't so it's
i'm actually not surprised that there's
but
they're trying not people don't want
that that's like look at the desperation
tactic it can reach a point so uh
northern ireland for instance i remember
i was getting a tour of northern ireland
and there's like a memorial for when you
know a group of guys went shot and
killed another group of guys
and you know on one side of town they're
like these guys were heroes another side
of town like these guys were villains
and it's just like there was no reason
to do that they didn't earn or gain
anything it was just pure tribalism
you can look at the literal tribalism
with you know what we've seen in africa
where one day one tribe goes out and
starts beating and killing the other
tribe for almost no reason just the
hatred within them when you start to see
some of these tweets where there was one
guy who said i wish all republicans get
cancer and die excruciating deaths
it's getting scary it's getting to this
point where
you you turn on the tv and you know
msnbc is not even trying to talk to you
but i mean even we do it we we know
there's a group of people who don't care
to watch us or even listen to what we
have to say so we just eventually tune
them out
but this creates separate spaces which
which is ripe for you know developing a
hatred more and more for the opponent
for the other and that's the problem
with with a lot of our elected leaders
and
you know biden is president right now so
you can say well you told me trump was
president that's a hypothetical biden is
president and he had his moment after
this shooting to say something and what
he chose was nothing but division and
attacking his political enemies he did
not offer the slightest sense of healing
of sorrow he didn't even evoke the names
and memories of these kids and talk
about you know just an evil in society
he talked about the nra and he talked
about republicans who won't pass
comments he resurrected 40-year-old
talking points it might have been the
election of 1976
right and so i agree with you you know
we are falling into these rival camps
but if our leaders don't start thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you